Now, that we have equations for the total number of gallons that Grant will buy,
let's compare the old equation we would have used to calculate how many gallons
of solution Grant would buy to the new equation that we're going to use. How are
these two lines related? Are they parallel? Are they perpendicular? Do they have
different slopes? Do they have the same slope? Do they have different
g-intercepts, or do they have the same g-intercept? Notice that we have
g-intercept here instead of a y-intercept, because our variable over here is a g
instead of a y. This is just different notation. Graphically, it really means
the same thing as a y-intercept since we would create axes to graph these
equations, with n as the horizontal axis, and g as the vertical axis.